por ahí del 2006 le preguntamos a
cualquier persona en especial a los
corredores de propiedades que hubieran
dicho siempre que en promedio a una
escala nacional el precio de las
viviendas sube a ti te podrían despedir
o quizás el precio del petróleo que haya
produciendo despidos en todo el mundo y
bueno si había muchos despedidos en una
cierta zona tal vez los precios de las
casas de esa misma zona bajarían un poco
me refiero las viviendas de esa misma
zona sin embargo en una escala nacional
el precio de las viviendas iban hacia
arriba siempre iban hacia arriba y bueno
esto es más o menos cierto desde la gran
depresión de 1929 el precio de las
viviendas sobre todo en eeuu ha ido
subiendo al 1 por ciento por año más o
menos pero algo fundamentalmente
asombroso ocurrió al comienzo de esta
década
aquí les voy a enseñar una página de
internet del caso
hitler y esta es probablemente el mejor
estimador de los precios de viviendas
que puedo encontrar pero bueno lo
importante aquí es ver el índice del
caso de hitler en el año 2000 se tiene
una casa que valía un millón de pesos
estamos hablando del 2000 y bueno
después en el 2004 esta casa vale cerca
de millón y medio de pesos digo estamos
hablando de una escala nacional
imagínate el precio de esta casa aumentó
un 46% y para el 2006 más aún llegó a un
máximo de 88 por ciento casi se ha
duplicado el precio que tenía en el año
2000 y bueno la pregunta que yo quiero
analizar es por qué está pasando esto
que lleva a los precios a aumentar tan
rápido y bueno esto lo digo porque en la
realidad la mayor parte de la historia
de eeuu el precio de las casas nunca
aumentó así de rápido y especialmente
considerando lo que estaba ocurriendo en
la economía general en esos años pero
bueno a ver esperen un poco si nosotros
hablamos de que el precio de alguna cosa
aumenta a qué me refiero bueno eso
quiere decir que la demanda tiene que
crecer mucho más rápido que lo que crece
la oferta no es así
así que echémosle un vistazo a todas las
posibles teorías que tenemos aquí cuáles
son los impulsores de la demanda que
podrían hacer que la demanda crezca más
rápido que la oferta
y bueno tal vez la población aumentó más
rápido para que la cantidad de viviendas
disponibles haya aumentado y por lo
tanto la demanda aumente pero vamos a
resumir lo mejor como población
solamente con población la población
aumenta a ver que otro impulsor de la
demanda y los ingresos ahora imagínense
que todos los salarios aumentaron los
ingresos se van hacia arriba y bueno
ahora pensemos en la oferta cuáles son
los impulsores de la oferta bueno pues
lo primero que se me ocurre son las
casas nuevas construidas las casas
nuevas construidas y bueno entonces si
usas el argumento clásico de la oferta y
la demanda el precio de las casas
aumentó en un 40% entre el año 2000 y el
2004 o porque habrá aumentado un 80 por
ciento entre el año 2000 y el año 2006
eso quiere decir que estas dinámicas que
yo tengo aquí tuvieron que haber crecido
mucho más rápido que esta dinámica que
tengo aquí esto quiere decir que la
población y los ingresos crecieron mucho
más rápido que lo que crecieron la
construcción de nuevas casas así que
vamos a ver si esto es verdad es el
control artículo en el new york times' y
de hecho lo podrían buscar en google
y seguro que lo pueden encontrar sin
problemas o hasta encontraron artículo
mejor pero esta es la búsqueda que estoy
haciendo yo con todas las prisas y las
carreras que tengo este es un artículo
del new york times' y este de aquí es un
pequeño gráfico que nos va a mostrar que
el promedio de ingresos reportados en
todas las declaraciones de impuestos
entre el 2000 y el 2004
de hecho disminuyó de hecho disminuyó
entre el 2000 y el 2004 y esto es
bastante interesante déjenme ver si lo
puedo si lo puedo poner todo aquí y aquí
dice el ingreso total reportado en
dólares del año 2004 y bueno ojo esto
está ajustado la inflación cayó un 1.4
por ciento pero como la población creció
durante este período el promedio real de
los ingresos se redujo más del doble
cayendo mil 641 dólares en un año o un
3% y bueno todo esto que está diciendo
que el ingreso total cayó un 1.4 por
ciento pero la población debió haber
crecido alrededor de 1.5 por ciento
es el promedio per cápita fue de un 3% y
entonces mejor dejarlo escribirlo como
un resumen que eso fue lo que pasó
sabemos que entre el 2000 y el 2004 esto
a una escala nacional la población
aumentó aproximadamente un 1.5 por
ciento 1.5 por ciento no es mucho pero
lo que quiero decir es que esto es para
un periodo de cuatro años lo que quiere
decir que creció en menos de un 1% por
ahí y ahora si vas al ingreso por
persona o bueno esto podemos decir como
el ingreso en la declaración de
impuestos por persona que es un
indicador bastante bueno los ingresos
disminuyeron en un 3% así que el dinero
total disponible que el artículo de new
york times dice nos muestra que
disminuyó el ingreso y podríamos decir
que decreció en un 1.4 por ciento si nos
fijamos en estas dos vamos a sacar que
es un 1.4 por ciento
por lo tanto acabamos de eliminar la
primera hipótesis que teníamos que era
que el ingreso había aumentado
estos años es decir que haya mucho más
dinero persiguiendo todas estas casas
eso no fue cierto pero bueno para estar
seguro tal vez por alguna razón las
casas fueron destruidas o el número de
casas construidas no mantuvo el ritmo me
refiero al ritmo del crecimiento de la
población y vamos a ver si podemos
encontrar datos al respecto y bueno de
hecho encontré esto este fue en 1999 y
dice que había 115 millones de casas
estimadas en eeuu entonces podemos decir
que aproximadamente en el año 2000 había
115 millones de casas construidas en
eeuu en el 2000 teníamos 115 millones de
casas construidas así que vamos a
fijarnos en cuántas casas fueron
construidas en este periodo del 2000 al
2004 en qué porcentaje aumentó la oferta
de viviendas y curiosamente encontré
estos datos que tengo ahora aquí esto es
el número de casas construidas
anualmente y no voy a pasar por toda la
crema y nata de las matemáticas pero si
vemos en el año 2000
en el año 2000 2001 estos en miles así
que en una base anual quizás sean unas
1.5 millones de casas
eso en el 2000 pero empezó a acelerarse
todo esto hasta el 2004 tanto que en el
año 2004 se estaba construyendo
aproximadamente 2 millones de casas al
año entonces en ese periodo podemos
decir que en promedio
digo puedes hacer el cálculo exacto y
encontrar esta página y hacer todas las
matemáticas detrás pero en promedio
podemos decir 1.8 millones de casas de
nuevas casas al año y bueno podemos
asumir que las casas destruidas son
bastante insignificantes no sé de muchos
barrios que se hayan destruido y
demolido todas sus casas y si fuese así
en la mayoría de los casos se construyen
casas nuevas así que podemos decir que
estas son casas nuevas totales podemos
ya calcular cuántas casas fueron
construidas es decir 1.8 millones por
cuatro años cuánto es eso 7.2 millones
de casas nuevas construidas en este
periodo y además partimos con una base
de que teníamos
15 millones de casas construidas para el
año 2000 por lo tanto voy a dividir esto
entre 115 me da que en ese periodo de
tiempo el número de viviendas aumentó en
un 6% la oferta de ofertas aumentó en un
6% y bueno ya con todo esto que es lo
que está pasando aquí entre el 2000 y el
2004 se construyeron una tonelada de
casas la oferta aumentó en un 6 por
ciento y por otra parte los ingresos
disminuyeron la gente fue despedida o
estaba indispuesta para trabajar o tal
vez empezó a trabajar por menos dinero y
esto quiere decir que el ingreso
disminuyó y además la población apenas
aumentó y si miramos la cantidad de
dólares que fueron ganados de hecho
disminuyó así que el dinero disponible
para pagar por estas casas disminuyó
también y además de todo eso estamos
diciendo que en ese mismo periodo de
tiempo el precio de las casas aumentó un
46% que está pasando con todo esto de
hecho siguió aumentando hasta el 2006
donde fue casi 1
y tantos por ciento esto parece ser muy
extraño si te das cuenta la economía
básica nos diría que si la oferta está
aumentando y la demanda disminuyendo los
precios en cualquier caso deberían de
bajar entonces qué ocurrió los voy a
dejar pensando en esto un poquito ya
saben tienen la regla de la oferta y la
demanda y lo que deberían hacer y bueno
en el próximo vídeo te voy a contar
francamente lo que yo creo por lo cual
yo estoy tan seguro de que los precios
de las casas subieron